cours de danse particulier pour danseurs
d'un jour à l'occasion de la semaine du
handicap qui se déroulait à plaisir
l'association cow boy advance hers
proposer une initiation à la country à
des adultes handicapés mentaux et
moteurs issus du foyer de villepreux
faut faire des adaptateurs de
chorégraphie parce que le but et c'est
que comme j'ai une association avec
trois niveaux de danse différents
si j'aimerais que mes débutants valide
et met des buts en fauteuil face les
mêmes danse donc il faut faire des
adaptations de chorégraphies pour qu'ils
puissent danser ensemble sur la même
pile dans ce partage et la même piste de
danse danse en ligne en cercle la
country comme certaines danses latines
permet de voir valides et personnes
handicapées se rejoindre sur une même
piste séduit par ses premiers pas en
rythme et leur nouveau partenaire les
apprentis danseurs se sont ordinaires le
temps d'une danse et s'affiche sous un
nouveau jour on a vu un résident qui
d'habitude est assez
réfractaire à ce qu'on lui dit et tout
est là il écoute
toutes les consignes du premier coup
donc ca ca c'est super quand les
découvre autrement habitué aux murs de
leur foyer c'est adulte handicapé était
particulièrement enthousiaste al'annonce
de cette sortie singulière pour les plus
mordus l'association cowboys dancers a
déjà ouvert un cours le samedi matin
pour les personnes porteuses d'un
handicap moteur